je pas saisie remarqué mais dans les
pubs les gens sont bizarres bref c'est
les pubs et reçu l'avis de ces partis
dans les pubs à s'est passé c'est chaud
je suis passé chez cipal personne
n'aurait dit je suis passé chez sosh
c'est compliqué à dire non salé par
prendre des gogos dans votre pub tout le
monde arrive à le dire dans les pays bas
rhin au no way ces derniers mois pour
toi ah bah c'est cool tu l'as bien pris
soin bata nouvelle voiture abîmée par
manon jean berbinau dans la vie ces
derniers dommage pour toi
ah ben c'est cool tu as bien compris
quoi à ta nouvelle voiture abîmée par
aman koala fait quoi t'es vraiment
qu'une colonne d'eau ne fait pas
semblant je sais tout jamais dû
t'épouser je le savais le gamin est pas
de moi mais je m'en bats les couilles de
gamins à ta gueule de cogne 2d bueno de
mer du fait rien de sa vie
merci je suis cash famille de merde dans
les publicités
[Musique]
dans la vie réelle alors garde ses
jeunes fils mais c'est tout ou rien et
des gouttes sur l'objectif
oui mais pourquoi tu filmes en arrosage
automatique aussi comme c'est en étant
je sais rien mais que c'est nul
des compute un mail à 4 4 les pubs
le bon pari de herta dans la vie
pourquoi moi j'ai pas mon jambon rôle et
les tomates cherry baptême pas mon genre
dont mais j'ai toujours cherché à nous
tiens parce qu'on peut vendre les pubs
pour moi la base d'une relation épanouie
c'est de partager des passions et des
valeurs communes comprendra dix mois la
base d'une relation épanouie c'est de
rencontrer que des riches sur internet
abbaoui non mais toutes les conneries
imaginer je discute avec une pauvre ou
pire je discute avec une moche du tout
récent trop riche pour une boîte ça
demande du temps pour une boîte ça
demande du temps pourquoi vous chantez
dans la vie ou une boîte ça demande du
temps
chante pas dans une banque barrez vous
tous les publics
[Musique]
l'appartement il est super je le prends
ah non mais c'est mort votre dossier
séoul si tu y as envie d'un appart va
avoir il ferme la monte au dossier pour
hiller tu te casses ne chantait pas si
tu y as c'est de la merde tous les pubs
je ris j'éternue j'ai des fuites
urinaires j'ai découvert une protection
incroyable dans une serviette vraiment
très fine
je ris j'éternue et j'ai des fuites
urinaires
qu'est-ce que je fais là je voulais être
comédienne monter sur scène récitez du
molière à faire une pub pour des couches
qu'est ce que j'ai dans mon parcours
pour me retrouver ici j'ai découvert une
protection incroyable dans une serviette
vraiment très fine avec always discrit
et moi s'il vous plaît j'ai besoin des
deux opus ils sont super épaisse et
sérieux dans les pubs et toi tu fais
quoi avec tes doigts marie cottin pas
j'aime pas quoi en fait question de
faire mecs ça fait 10 ans que je
pourrais faire saint astier mais en
disant tu apprends un instrument dieu de
la guitare [ __ ] mais tout le monde me
dit ça [ __ ] bnr ça non mais si si si
si c'est très bien ce que tu fais parce
que oui
et puis bah il faut de l'argent pour se
développer j'ai une bande mais il faut
de l'argent pour se développer
oui mais au cours de mon compte en
banque dans la rue devant tout le monde
on peut pas faire ça dans un bureau
comme d'habitude elle mais c'est madame
mort c'est ma prof de maths vous à des
primes de tuer dans le rouge
dépenser mille sept cent balles dans des
sms pour secretstory la bouffonne
maintenant c'est bien
la mycose de long est contagieuse et
paraît peu hygiéniques traiter la
immédiatement et xi lors la vie
bon bah je met du vernis on n'y verra
que du feu ont ce pouvoir dans les pubs
le dali swiffer nettoie partout dans la
maison et se rendre à vis du même nom
mais mec c'est dégueulasse chez toi en
fait on peut pas marcher ça juste
l'esprit de ferrette
c'est dégueulasse dans les pubs
retrouver l'efficacité cillit bang ravi
mais c'est quoi cette cuisine
dégueulasse mais j'essayais de bon gars
mais c'est pas ça c'est juste regardant
faits soient propres un moment il ya
tout eu plus le manga en regard d'or en
a pour plus tard il la deuxième paire
offerte je peut la choisir librement
dans tout magasin et celle là oui aussi
sa vie et celle là non ça c'est mes
lunettes et c'est celle que j'ai choisie
elle me trouvais ça qu'aucun ont bien
seul messi s'est fâché vous êtes bientôt
10 millions d'abonnés à ma chaîne
youtube ce qui va vous être bientôt dix
mille jouets cache pas je prépare une
vidéo spéciale pour l'occasion un truc
un peu dingue que j'ai jamais fait sur
ma chaîne un truc aventure à vivre ou de
4,5 m du coup je lance officiellement
l'objectif 10 millions d'abonnés
c'est officiel on peut le faire week end
de wade c'est à dire on peut faire un
américain je compte sur vous
[Applaudissements]